[Music]  breaking ted from our eight news now  i-team fbi agents have served a search  warrant on nevada's top gop official  agents sees the cell phone of state  republican chairman michael mcdonald  reportedly as part of an investigation  into the fake elector's scheme now this  was initiated at the end of the 2020  presidential election sources confirming  to the i-team that mcdonald's phone was  surrendered to agents mcdonald's  attorney was unavailable today similar  subpoenas are reportedly being served on  republican officials in other states our  i-team has previously reported that  department of justice officials have  been investigating the scheme to create  slate's alternate electors in multiple  background states  nevada's gop sent phony electoral  certificates to the national archives  that matter is currently being  investigated by the house january 6  committee we will of course have further  details as the story develops